so this is Donnie like the character I
used to play in demo reel which could
have been a segue in the last episode
that instead you went from why-wolves
what's demo reel even the people who are
in it didn't watch it that's how little
an impact it made I am so happy thank
you for that no problem anywho okay so
this is Donnie and what the hell was he
again grass ogre I think it was grass so
who care okay I remember right um kind
of a myth design for me but I don't know
I guess he's supposed to be sort of like
just a big bully jerks so I guess that's
how they decided um but the I he's in
this neighborhood that's literally these
little house people they're there people
are houses and I love the design of them
I just love that idea that there's just
these little houses right around they
have like people faces out of them and
they apparently have bodies inside the
houses to about actually really kind of
free but he takes the house off and
there's like this triangle square shape
but he's a jerk that nobody likes and
Finn and Jake come along they try to
make him less of a jerk but it turns out
there's these things called why-wolves I
forgot why they were called why-wolves
though well that's the reason because
we're just interested in stuff instead
they were inquisitive Wolf's so loved to
go back and forth between you know
something like this and something like
this so seem to that's their stick and
but now the now Dottie is a is a nice
guy Jake made him much nicer and told
him that if he sings little songs with
Ryan's to teach people lessons that'll
work and Finn and Jake dragged him over
there and they say you gotta be a jerk
again and so they make fun of his songs
they're really cruel to him to make him
angry to a myth the oven oxygen which is
a great term I love that term and it
works it scares all the walls off but
the
outside he's a jerk again and he hates
everybody and he hates Finn and Jake and
Finn and Jake just it Finn at least
feels really bad it's it's sort of this
great moment where it's like it's both
really funny really tragic when Finn is
just like you know I'm sorry honey
my thing is that Woody's every hit like
the little tear it's just like yeah and
it's just it's really funny and really
sad and they just sort of walk away and
I think even Donnie isn't sure if like a
good thing or a bad thing happened yeah
for the most part I wasn't getting into
the episode that much until that ending
I do really like that ending I think
that's like a surprisingly heavy tragic
ending you know just some where you see
some times where somebody has to suffer
something it's something that feels
wrong has to be done because in the law
in the big long some long terms are in a
long term it's actually better over here
and the big picture is actually better
and they say in the Bible the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
no but at the same time by him being
such a jerk it's like he hates himself
and he hates everybody around him but
then he also finds he likes being a jerk
which I guess is good it's good for him
at least he's happy but everyone else is
miserable so it's this it's it's an
interesting balancing act I think should
have a lot of life kind of works that
way it's just like burying I mean with
some people it's like oh just not taking
things for granted and others it's
varying levels of misery yeah you know
just how miserable can I be can I find
joy and being miserable and that's it's
not very optimistic upbeat way of
looking at things but there it is there
are some people that see things like
that and I don't want to say it but
there is a part of me that serves as
that's kind of how some things and some
people need to be you know it's like
that balance has to be capped or arid
it's always gonna go with imbalance but
you know maybe it's not how it needs to
be it's just how it's going to be and
it sucks Adventure Time so yeah I love
to know your thoughts after that like
little bit that I said oh yeah well how
am I supposed to follow that demo reels
is great watch it III don't know if I
fully agree with the whole that's the
way that like I know you kind of said
one thing and then you said another says
sometimes it has to be that way I don't
know if it has to be that way but in
this one the reason why I brought the
whole needs the many how it needs it
it's kind of like this they're
sacrificing Donny to save a whole bunch
of other people they realize that Donny
who is now a good guy they're gonna have
to kind of make him a bad guy again just
to save an entire town of people and
it's like well who do you save the
singular or the whole bunch it's it's
kind of it kind of sucks because they're
in a really tight spot it's it's like
that I love that term democracy
democracy is the worst form of
government except for all the others
yeah it's kind of a case here where it's
like look this isn't a good situation
but it's better than every other option
that's yeah you know and I think there
is with a last show is I think there is
always the especially like kid show is
it I see a lot of superhero stuff to
where there's this thought of no you can
always find a way around it there's
always an answer and I don't know if
that's always true sometimes the answer
is just going to be you know that there
is no answer or that sometimes there is
just gonna be misery or suffering or
whatever you know it's just and he had
to accept that you know you have to
accept that sometimes that's just gonna
be kind of what the solution is um you
know and it's it doesn't feel good and
it sucks but you know sometimes that's
just life and it's it's a pain but
there's a lot of good things worth
fighting for and that's why you stay
alive and do all that good stuff but
it's just gonna be tough stuff too
well if you look back a few episodes
that you guys actually were talking
about the one where Finn and
we fixed all the problems just now
you've got the complete reverse where
they couldn't fix everything so they
kind of almost deal with both issues in
the exact same season yeah it's so yes
I'll say it actually almost reminded me
a not specific episode but can remind me
of like a Batman story or like the a Mia
series or something like that just so we
know it I know it sounds but just where
you see something happen as just like
sometimes there are no happy endings or
you just see the tragedy you just not
like yep that's life you know it's like
a Clint Eastwood movie you just sir
watching you just go well I use
your college as well movies watch
it you see what could be this beautiful
ending with a beautiful alright this
beautiful movie of the beautiful ending
instead it's just this shitty tragedy
like this great tragedy just go well
but life's full of those doing its
you know I don't think it's necessarily
a bad thing to know going in you know I
think we teach kids a lot of good stuff
and all have optimistic stuff and that's
the way to go in you know but you gotta
love know hey that's not always happy
endings sometimes shit's gonna happen
well yeah you can't save everyone
yeah so deep philosophical talk they're
from a grass ogre who has a leaf over
his junk buck he turned that leaf around
he did nothing he turned it back yes
anything else for this episode master
one other thing I like they call me
master I keep doing that um one other
thing actually and cuz I almost forgot
that and I pride touched if I but in the
opening when they come out and they are
like it was it like sit what safety
guard or Safety Patrol that's the safety
patrol stuff
I love how happy and I just love how
they get into everything even if it's
like the nerdiest most why would a bike
care about this thing in the world it's
like they just get so into it and I I
don't know in my opinion when I see
people they like get obsessed over
something like how could get obsessed
over there immediately sir I hit myself
in the head a you
what let them there they're lovin it and
I just every time I see Finn and Jake
just get so into whatever strange thing
I go why are they into that I'd suddenly
say you know it doesn't matter why
they're into it it's they love it it's
not there anybody it's so cool and they
just they think the world of it and even
if something is lame and silly as safety
patrol you know what good for friggin
them because I I don't know that
happiness is contagious and I think
that's it's a good thing to be again
just on kids shows just get that
positive happiness just flowing and
contagious in what is otherwise a very
depressing episode is that why you
pulled me in on this whole v-log thing
because I was so happy about Adventure
Time and I was probably approximate
safety patrol I was lost at the
beginning but now I'm found and you
showed me the way
hole so no you're my bitch now right I
like to bear when you called me master
yes sir we should go to bondage dungeon
later